My dad's ATM password was 1119 till the day he died. 1119 was also in the password for his home WiFi network. 1119 was shorthand for 1119 Bayard Street, which is where his grandfather, my great grandfather, owned a tiny grocery store on the ground floor of a house in downtown Baltimore in the 1920s, '30s, '40s, '50s.
我爸爸的提款机密码一直都是1119，直到他去世那天。他的家庭WiFi网络密码里也有1119。1119是贝亚德街1119号的缩写，那是他祖父，也就是我的曾祖父，在1920、30、40和50年代在巴尔的摩市中心一栋房子的底层开的一家小型杂货店。
Picture a neighborhood bodega, and you've got the general size of this thing. The family lived upstairs, worked downstairs. So much happened at 1119 Bayard. So many things about our family were set in motion there. But my sisters and I only got little scraps of stories about the place, this handful of family-defining origin stories that got trotted out now and then.
想象一下街角的杂货店，你就能大致了解它的大小。一家人住在楼上，在楼下工作。在贝亚德街1119号发生过太多的事。关于我们家庭的很多事情都是在那里开始的。但我姐妹和我只从那里得到了一些零碎的故事，就是那一小部分被偶尔提起、定义了我们家族起源的故事。
Like, for instance, there was the one about the chickens. My dad and his brother Lenny both worked in the store from the time they were little kids. And chickens were slaughtered at the store, which freaked them out, both of them. To the point where, decades later, as grown men, neither of them ate chicken, and they'd explain this was the reason why.
比如，关于鸡的故事。我爸爸和他哥哥莱尼从小就在店里帮忙。店里要屠宰鸡，这把他们俩都吓坏了。以至于几十年后，作为成年人，他们俩都不吃鸡肉，他们会解释说这就是原因。
Or there's the story about my great grandfather's bookkeeping skills. I'm actually named for my great grandfather, Isadore Friedlander. My parents chose Ira instead of Isadore because Isadore Glass is a parsable English sentence-- "Is a door glass?" My mom once told me that they picked Ira over the alternatives because it sounded less Jewish to them, which just goes to show how completely, utterly Jewish their entire world was back then.
又或者是我曾祖父的记账技巧的故事。我其实是以我曾祖父伊萨多·弗里德兰德的名字命名的。我父母选了艾拉这个名字而不是伊萨多，因为伊萨多·格拉斯是一句可解析的英语句子——“Is a door glass（门是玻璃做的吗）？”。我妈妈曾经告诉我，他们选择艾拉而不是其他名字，是因为在他们看来这个名字听起来没那么犹太化，这正好说明了当时他们的整个世界是多么彻底、完全地被犹太文化所包围。
I've heard all my life what a kind-hearted man Isadore was and a soft touch, which brings me to this next story we would hear now and then. During the Depression, when everybody in the neighborhood was broke and buying on credit, Isadore set up a system where every customer would have a little book, like this flimsy paper thing, where he would write down what they owed.
我一生都在听人说伊萨多是一个多么心地善良、耳根子软的人，这让我想到了我们偶尔会听到的下一个故事。大萧条时期，当街区里的每个人都破产并赊账购物时，伊萨多建立了一个系统，每个顾客都会有一个小本子，就像这种薄薄的纸片，他在上面记下他们欠的债。
But the thing about the system was the customer kept the book. Maybe you see the problem with this. All the time, customers would show up at the store and say, I lost my book. And Isadore would say to them, ah, it's OK. What do you think you owe? And then they'd say some not very high number. And he'd write it down and hand them a new book to take home.
但这个系统的关键在于，顾客自己保管本子。也许你看出问题所在了。顾客们总是出现在店里说，我把本子弄丢了。而伊萨多会对他们说，啊，没关系。你觉得你欠多少钱？然后他们会报出一个不太高的数字。他就会写下来，再给他们一个新本子带回家。
Years later, my dad became a certified public accountant. And this became one of those "the day Peter Parker got bit by the radioactive spider" sort of origin stories, what bad bookkeeping he saw his grandfather do at 1119 Bayard and how he was going to do better.
多年以后，我爸爸成为了一名注册会计师。这成了那些“彼得·帕克被放射性蜘蛛咬伤那天”之类的起源故事之一，他看到了他祖父在贝亚德街1119号糟糕的记账方式，以及他打算如何做得更好。
I'm sure some good things happened at 1119 Bayard, but those stories didn't get passed down. We heard painful things. My dad was miserable working there. So was his brother. His mom, my Grandma Frieda, got out of the store, went to college, taught Latin in junior high school, but then got dragged back into the family business against her will, like Michael Corleone, when her dad, Isadore, got sick.
我相信在贝亚德街1119号发生过一些好事，但那些故事并没有流传下来。我们听到的都是痛苦的事情。我爸爸在那里工作得很痛苦。他哥哥也是。他的妈妈，也就是我的弗里达祖母，逃出了杂货店，上了大学，在初中教拉丁语，但当她父亲伊萨多生病时，她又像迈克尔·柯里昂一样违背意愿被拖回了家族生意中。
I visited 1119 Bayard-- I don't know-- maybe half a dozen times in my life, a dozen times. Usually it would happen when my Uncle Lenny came to town. He and my dad would drive us all downtown, and we'd stand outside 1119 Bayard. And the two of them would marvel at the place, at the fact of it, and I think at the distance they'd come from there-- my dad with his accounting firm out in the suburbs, my uncle, who became a surgeon and moved to San Diego, their kids raised in the kind of middle class comfort that we ate all the chicken we could ever want.
我访问过贝亚德街1119号——我不知道——可能是我这一生中去过五六次，甚至十几次吧。通常是在我莱尼叔叔来城里的时候。他和爸爸会开车带我们所有人去市中心，我们就站在贝亚德街1119号外面。他们俩会惊叹于这个地方，感叹事实本身，我想也是感叹他们从那里走出了多远——我爸爸在郊区经营着他的会计师事务所，我叔叔成为了外科医生并搬到了圣地亚哥，他们的孩子在那种我们想吃多少鸡肉就能吃多少的中产阶级的舒适环境中长大。
I always found those trips disappointing. We'd take a picture and hang around there on the sidewalk. It's not a store anymore. It's just somebody's house. It doesn't look like anything. A rowhouse in a block of rowhouses. At some point a few years ago, somebody painted a cheerful Christian mural on one side of the building with a quote from the Book of Mark.
我总是觉得那些旅行很令人失望。我们拍张照，然后在人行道上闲逛。那不再是一家店了。它只是某人的家。它看起来没什么特别的。在一排排联排别墅中的一栋。几年前的某个时候，有人在建筑的一侧画了一幅欢快的基督教壁画，上面引述了马可福音的一句话。
Every time I've gone to 1119 Bayard and stood on the sidewalk, I've tried to picture it, my family there long ago, Frieda in her 30s, at the cash register against her will, my dad as a little boy, opening boxes and putting stuff on shelves. I'm not great at that kind of thing. It's like trying to summon ghosts with a Ouija board, and the little pointer refuses to budge.
每次我去贝亚德街1119号站在人行道上，我都试图想象一下，我的家人很久以前在那里，弗里达三十多岁时违心地坐在收银台前，我爸爸还是个小男孩，打开箱子把东西摆在货架上。我不擅长做那种事。这就像试图用通灵板召唤鬼魂，而那个小指针却拒绝移动。
We've all got these spots from our family's past, and we go to them. And they're like Civil War battlefields that have been washed of blood long ago. We pause there and look at the trees and the grassy fields. And we want-- what? Some connection to something. I am who I am partly because of this place. But now it's mute.
我们都有这些来自家庭过去的地点，我们也会去那里。它们就像早已洗净血迹的内战战场。我们停在那里，看着树木和草地。我们想要什么？与某事物的某种联系。我之所以是我，部分原因是由于这个地方。但现在，它沉默不语。
So we take a selfie and try to tune into the past, like a distant radio station whose signal we can just barely make out.
所以我们拍张自拍，试图调入过去，就像一个遥远的电台，信号极其微弱，我们只能勉强听清。
Today on our program, we have a story of somebody else who heads out to a place like that from his family's history, looking for answers. And he gets so much more out of it than I ever did at 1119 Bayard about who he is. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有一个故事，关于另一个人前往他家族历史上这样一个地方，寻找答案。他从中得到的关于他是谁的收获，比我在贝亚德街1119号得到的要多得多。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
OK, so we're devoting today's entire program to this one story. It's by Boen Wang, who we've had on our show before. He's a producer whose work has its own very distinct sound and feeling. That's one of the things that we, on our staff, really like about him. Here is what he put together today for you.
好的，我们今天要把整个节目献给这个故事。它是由我们节目以前有过合作的制作人博恩·王制作的。他是一位作品有其独特声音和感觉的制作人。这也是我们员工真正喜欢他的原因之一。这是他今天为你准备的内容。
August 1989.
1989年8月。
My dad is in an airport. He's flown from Beijing to Tokyo to San Francisco to Denver to Oklahoma City, almost missing his flight multiple times because he can't understand the announcements in English. He is here to get a PhD from the University of Oklahoma. He's here for a new life, a life where he doesn't sit chain smoking cigarettes at his boring job in a Jeep factory, while living in a tiny room with no running water or heating or cooling. He wants a life where something changes.
我爸爸在机场。他从北京飞往东京，再到旧金山、丹佛，最后抵达俄克拉荷马城，因为听不懂英语广播，他好几次差点误机。他来这里是为了在俄克拉荷马大学攻读博士学位。他为了新生活而来，在那样的生活中，他不必在一个吉普车工厂的枯燥工作中一边坐着抽烟，一边住在一个没有自来水、没有供暖或制冷的小房间里。他想要一个有所改变的生活。
It's the middle of the night in the Oklahoma City airport. He had sent a letter to the university with the date and time of his arrival, so that someone could pick him up. He scans the crowd, looking for someone holding a sign with his name on it, but finds no one. One by one, the crowd thins out until my dad is stuck in the middle of this airport in the middle of this foreign country, a stranger in a strange land.
那是深夜的俄克拉荷马城机场。他曾寄了一封信给大学，写明了抵达的日期和时间，以便有人能去接他。他扫视人群，寻找拿着写有他名字牌子的人，但什么也没发现。人群一个个散去，直到我爸爸被困在这个异国他乡机场的中央，成了一个陌生土地上的陌生人。
Attention, airport. This is the final boarding call for the airline flight 382--
注意，机场。这是航空公司382次航班的最后登机通知——
So you were alone?
所以你当时是一个人？
Yeah, I was alone. And I was looking for someone to pick me up. But all the passengers left, and no one stayed around, and no sign for picking me up. So as I was trying to leave, thinking what I'm going to do, and then this nice gentleman approached me.
是的，我是一个人。我在找人接我。但所有乘客都走了，没有人在周围，也没有人举牌接我。所以当我试图离开，想着我该怎么办的时候，这位友善的先生向我走来。
This nice gentleman, the first white American my dad ever talks to, introduces himself as Dave. Dave isn't his real name. I changed it to protect his privacy.
这位友善的先生，是我爸爸第一次交谈的白人美国人，介绍自己叫戴夫。戴夫不是他的真名。我改了名字以保护他的隐私。
And he comes here to pick me up. He's about the same height, and he wears glasses. He has a very warm smile.
他来这儿接我。他跟我差不多高，戴着眼镜。他有非常温暖的笑容。
A warm smile.
温暖的笑容。
Yeah, he smiles warmly and said that he is going to take me. So I was so happy to see him.
是的，他微笑着，说他要带我走。所以我见到他非常高兴。
Dave takes my dad to his car and drives half an hour south to his home in Norman, the college town that surrounds the University of Oklahoma. My dad meets Dave's wife and, finally, having reached the end of his trans-Pacific ordeal--
戴夫带着我爸爸上了他的车，开车向南半小时回到他在诺曼的家，那是一座围绕着俄克拉荷马大学的大学城。我爸爸见到了戴夫的妻子，终于，在经历了跨太平洋的磨难后——
He told me to sleep in this room. So I took a shower and went to sleep.
他让我睡在这个房间里。我洗了个澡就睡着了。
Dave is a Christian, the leader of a local church's Chinese ministry. Dave gives my dad a bible, the first English language book he studies from cover to cover, and invites him to a weekly Bible study and Sunday service.
戴夫是一名基督徒，是当地教会中文事工的领袖。戴夫给了我爸爸一本圣经，这是他从头到尾学习的第一本英语书，并邀请他参加每周的圣经学习和主日崇拜。
In time, my dad will accept Christ. So will my mom after she arrives in America later that year. My parents will raise me and my older sister as Christians. We will attend church every Sunday in Oklahoma and then in Philly, where my dad finds a job and where I grow up. It's the perfect conversion story, the sort of testimony you'd share in front of an audience at church.
久而久之，我爸爸接受了基督。我妈妈在同年晚些时候抵达美国后也接受了。我父母把我姐姐和我培养成基督徒。我们在俄克拉荷马州，后来在费城，每周日都去教堂，我在那里长大，爸爸在那里找到了工作。这是一个完美的悔改故事，那种你会会在教堂观众面前分享的见证。
My parents grew up during the Cultural Revolution, when the Communist Party suppressed any expression of religion. They were atheists by default. Their conversion here in America goes against everything they learned in China. The only problem with this story is me. After 22 years of Christianity, I left and never came back.
我父母是在文化大革命期间长大的，当时共产党压制任何宗教表达。他们默认是无神论者。他们在来到美国后的悔改违背了他们在国内学到的一切。这个故事唯一的问题是我。在经历了22年的基督教生活后，我离开了，再也没有回来。
(SUBJECT) YOUNG BOEN WANG: Have you ever felt depressed? Perhaps a bit blue? Did you ever have an existential crisis and start to question the very foundation of your faith?
（采访对象）年轻的博恩·王：你有没有感到沮丧过？也许有点忧郁？你有没有经历过存在主义危机，开始质疑你信仰的基础？
I am raised in the church. I go to Sunday school, and worship service, and youth group, and Bible study, which I come to lead. Every break, I go to a retreat that's held at a camp near Lancaster, out in Amish country. When I'm 17, I make this promo video for our upcoming spring youth retreat.
我在教会长大。我参加主日学、崇拜仪式、青年团契和圣经研习班，后来我甚至开始带班。每次放假，我都会参加在兰开斯特附近的一个营地举办的静修会，那是在阿米什地区。17岁时，我为即将到来的春季青年静修会制作了这个宣传视频。
(SUBJECT) YOUNG BOEN WANG: Maybe you have doubts about your faith. Maybe you've been a Christian for many years, but you're still uncertain about some things. Maybe you're new to Christianity and have a lot of questions. Either way, you should take the opportunity to go to the spring youth retreat. Don't believe me? Just listen to these satisfied customers.
（采访对象）年轻的博恩·王：也许你对你的信仰有疑问。也许你做基督徒已经很多年了，但你对某些事情仍然不确定。也许你刚接触基督教，有很多问题。不管怎样，你应该抓住机会参加春季青年静修会。不信我？听听这些满意的客户怎么说。
At first, I wasn't too sure about this retreat thing, you know? I mean, like, people going to woods, singing, worshiping, isn't that what cults do? But then I went to it, and it was really interesting. We went singing, we worshipped. And it wasn't a cult at all. I mean, you should definitely go.
起初，我不确定这个静修会，你知道吗？我的意思是，比如，人们去树林里，唱歌，崇拜，那不是邪教做的吗？但后来我去了，它真的很棒。我们唱歌，我们崇拜。那根本不是邪教。我的意思是，你一定要去。
In retrospect, this sounds like a cry for help. I'm totally not trapped in a cult, haha. Being immersed for decades in this not-cult didn't just shape my behavior-- it rewired my brain. Like, even today, when I'm washing the dishes, I'll be thinking about how this Scrub Daddy that I'm using is falling apart. And I should probably get some new sponges from the supermarket.
回想起来，这听起来像是求救信号。我绝对没有陷入邪教，哈哈。几十年来沉浸在这个非邪教组织中，不仅塑造了我的行为，还重新连结了我的大脑。比如，即使是今天，当我洗碗的时候，我也会思考我用的这个“Scrub Daddy”海绵是怎么散架的。我应该从超市买些新海绵。
And Jesus Christ, remember that time at the food bazaar in Flatbush when I almost ran my shopping cart into that old lady, and she yelled at me? God, I'm such a worthless piece of shit. But anyway, I should probably go to Giant Eagle to get some sponges.
还有耶稣基督，还记得那次在弗拉特布什的食品集市，我差点把购物车撞到那位老太太身上，她还对我大吼大叫吗？天哪，我真是个一文不值的废物。但无论如何，我应该去巨人鹰超市买些海绵。
And Jesus Christ, remember that time when I met up with the Arts Council guy at the 61C Cafe across the street from the Giant Eagle, and we said goodbye, but then we were walking the same way and awkwardly made more conversation until we reached his car? God, I'm such a worthless piece of shit.
还有耶稣基督，还记得那次我在巨人鹰超市街对面的61C咖啡馆遇见艺术委员会的家伙，我们道别后，又走在同一条路上，尴尬地聊了一会儿，直到我们到达他的车旁吗？天哪，我真是个一文不值的废物。
But anyway, I should email the landlord about how the dishwasher doesn't work so I don't have to hand wash these dishes. It hasn't worked this entire time. And Jesus Christ, it's been almost a year since I moved into this apartment, and I still haven't emailed him. God, why am I such a procrastinator? I'm such a worthless piece of shit.
但无论如何，我应该给房东发邮件说洗碗机坏了，这样我就不用手洗这些碗了。它一直没用过。还有耶稣基督，我搬进这个公寓都快一年了，我还是没给他发邮件。天哪，为什么我这么拖延？我真是个一文不值的废物。
Sometimes I whisper it to myself. I'm a worthless piece of shit. I hate myself. This is the main thing I learned from Christianity, that I'm a worthless piece of shit. And listen, I know that that's not the main message of the Gospel. I know Jesus teaches us that we're redeemed by His sacrifice, that we're all children of God. But all that nice, feel-good stuff bounced right off of me.
有时我会悄悄对自己说。我是一个一文不值的废物。我讨厌自己。这是我从基督教中学到的主要东西，我是一个一文不值的废物。听着，我知道那不是福音的主要信息。我知道耶稣教导我们，我们因祂的牺牲而得救，我们都是上帝的孩子。但所有那些美好、让人感觉良好的东西都直接从我身上弹开了。
What was drilled into my mind and what I really internalized is that while I'm a child of God, I'm also a child of Adam, who ate the forbidden fruit offered to him by Eve and whose original sin I inherit. Christians remind you of it all the time. I was at a wedding where the groom's brother told the newlyweds they need to never forget that they're broken sinners-- at a celebration of the couple.
钻进我脑子里的，并且我真正内化的是，虽然我是上帝的孩子，但我也是亚当的孩子，他吃了夏娃给他的禁果，而我继承了他的原罪。基督徒们总是提醒你这一点。我参加过一场婚礼，新郎的兄弟告诉新婚夫妇，他们永远不要忘记自己是破碎的罪人——在庆祝这对夫妇的日子里。
So I learned to hate myself. I need to punish myself every moment of every waking hour of every day for my sinfulness, which morphs into a need to punish myself for anything I've ever done that's vaguely embarrassing. For years, I hated talking about myself because I hated myself. If I'm at a social event and meet someone new, I'll be like, so where do you live? How long have you been there for? How do you like it? Where are you from? What school did you go to?
所以我学会了恨自己。我需要在每天清醒的每一刻、每一天惩罚自己，为了我的罪恶感，这演变成一种需要，因为我做过的任何稍微尴尬的事情而惩罚自己。多年来，我讨厌谈论自己，因为我讨厌自己。如果我在社交场合遇到新朋友，我会说，你住在哪儿？你住在那里多久了？你喜欢那里吗？你是哪里人？你上什么学校？
And if someone asks me a question, like what I do for a living, I'm like, oh, uh, well, you know, I make podcasts or whatever. It's stupid. And then I do rhetorical jujitsu and redirect back to the other person. What do you do for a living? How did you get into that? How do you like it?
如果有人问我一个问题，比如我是做什么工作的，我会说，哦，嗯，你知道，我做播客什么的。这太蠢了。然后我做了一套修辞上的柔道，把话题引回到对方身上。你是做什么工作的？你是怎么入行的？你喜欢它吗？
Humility is a big part of Christianity. The good are humble, quiet, and meek, while the evil are loud, boisterous, and proud. As Solomon teaches us in Proverbs, "When pride comes, then comes disgrace. But with humility comes wisdom."
谦卑是基督教的重要组成部分。好人谦虚、安静、温顺，而邪恶的人喧闹、浮夸、骄傲。正如所罗门在箴言中所教导的那样，“骄傲来，羞耻也来；谦逊人却有智慧。”
So if I don't want to disgrace myself, I need to make sure the attention is always on the other person. I need to stay humble and never answer anyone's questions about me. Because if I talk about myself, they'd soon discover my fundamental worthless piece of shit-ness and be as disgusted with me as I am with myself.
所以如果我不想让自己丢脸，我就必须确保注意力始终在对方身上。我必须保持谦卑，永远不要回答任何人关于我的问题。因为如果我谈论自己，他们很快就会发现我本质上是个一文不值的废物，并像我讨厌自己一样厌恶我。
Besides, who would want to talk to me in the first place? Who would possibly want to get to know me, befriend me, or, God forbid, date me? Sex was out of the question, even as an adult living on my own. As Jesus says in the Sermon on the Mount, anyone who looks at a woman lustfully has already committed adultery with her in his heart. So not only is it immoral to have sex, to just think about sex is a sin.
再说，一开始谁会想跟我说话呢？谁会想了解我，跟我做朋友，或者，上帝保佑，跟我约会呢？性是根本不可能的，即使是作为一个独自生活的成年人。正如耶稣在登山宝训中所说，凡看见妇女就动淫念的，心里已经与她犯奸淫了。所以，不仅发生性关系是不道德的，仅仅思考性也是一种罪。
I held on to that even after I left the church and graduated college. I simply cannot imagine myself ever dating. When I thought about the future, I pictured myself getting frozen fish nuggets from Trader Joe's, frozen hash browns and tartar sauce from Giant Eagle, and eating them together as the saddest fish and chips in the world, while watching through all of Twin Peaks, which is what I did my first semester in grad school, living with Craigslist roommates in a single room in Pittsburgh.
即使在我离开教堂并大学毕业后，我也坚持这一点。我简直无法想象自己会去约会。当我想到未来时，我看到自己从Trader Joe's买冷冻鱼块，从巨人鹰超市买冷冻薯饼和塔塔酱，然后把它们放在一起吃，这是世界上最悲伤的炸鱼薯条，同时看完所有的《双峰》，这正是我研究生第一学期，和Craigslist找的室友住在匹兹堡的一个单人间里做的事情。
I read an interview in The Cut with a, quote, "58-year-old virgin," who said that the worst part about his life is, quote, "laying alone at night, falling asleep, and then getting up in the morning and remembering you're alone." I read that, and I was like, yep. All right, here we go.
我在《The Cut》杂志上读到一篇采访，对象是一位58岁的处男，他说他生活中最糟糕的部分是“晚上独自躺着，睡着了，然后早上醒来想起你还是一个人。”我读了那篇文章，我想，是的。好吧，开始了。
At age 25, I started dating my partner and now fiancée, Grace. They're the first person I ever dated. We saw the movie Challengers the other day, the horny Zendaya tennis movie about three tennis players who fuck each other while fucking each other over. On the drive back from the theater, Grace was like--
25岁时，我开始和我的伴侣，现在的未婚妻格蕾丝约会。他们是我约会过的第一个人。前几天我们看了电影《挑战者》，那部关于三个网球运动员在互相伤害的同时互相上床的性感赞达亚网球电影。从电影院回家的路上，格蕾丝说——
Wow, the horny Zendaya tennis movie sure was horny, don't you think?
哇，那部性感赞达亚网球电影真的很性感，你不觉得吗？
And I was like--
我回答说——
Uh, well, I just really like the soundtrack by Trent Reznor and Atticus Ross of Nine Inch Nails. They also did the music for The Social Network and Gone Girl and the Watchmen TV show.
嗯，我真的很喜欢九寸钉乐队的特伦特·雷诺和阿提克斯·罗斯制作的配乐。他们也为《社交网络》、《消失的爱人》和《守望者》电视剧做过音乐。
Right, but the movie was also, like, really horny, right? Did it make you horny?
对，但那部电影也真的很性感，对吧？它让你感到性感了吗？
Uh, maybe. I don't know. It's just that Nine Inch Nails actually released an album of instrumentals in 2008 entirely through a Creative Commons license, so you don't have to pay any licensing fees. I actually used some of their songs in my podcasts.
呃，也许吧。我不知道。只是九寸钉乐队实际上在2008年完全通过知识共享许可发行了一张纯音乐专辑，所以你不需要支付任何授权费。我实际上在我的播客中用过他们的一些歌。
Boen, did the horny Zendaya tennis movie make you horny? Why are you being so immature about this?
博恩，那部性感的赞达亚网球电影让你感到性感了吗？你为什么在这件事上表现得这么幼稚？
I don't know what exactly happened in this moment, but I felt like a child. I felt swallowed by an overwhelming feeling of shame-- shame about sex, about sexual desire, and simply being a sexual being, for having a body. For a long time, I wish I didn't have a body, that I was a floating consciousness, freed from the shame and guilt of the flesh.
我不知道那一刻到底发生了什么，但我感觉像个孩子。我感到被一种强烈的羞耻感所吞没——关于性，关于性欲，仅仅作为一个性存在，因为有一个身体。很长一段时间，我希望我没有身体，希望我是一个漂浮的意识，从肉体的羞耻和内疚中解放出来。
It's been seven years since I left Christianity, but the effects are still there. These mental grooves are so well worn at this point, it's basically instinct. Where does my fucked up-ness come from? Well, I think I can trace all of this back to my dad at the Oklahoma City airport.
离开基督教已经七年了，但影响仍然存在。这些心理沟壑在这一点上已经非常深了，这基本上是本能。我的操蛋感来自哪里？嗯，我想我可以把这一切追溯到我爸爸在俄克拉荷马城机场。
The story of my dad waiting for someone to pick him up at the airport has taken on an almost mythological significance to me, this moment that sealed my fate years before I even existed, because as he stood in the terminal, he also stood at a crossroads. Is there an alternate reality where Dave doesn't pick him up and someone else does instead, someone who isn't a Christian, and my dad never converts, and my life is so much better as a result?
我爸爸在机场等候接机的故事对我来说具有了某种神话般的意义，这一刻在我还没出生前几年就决定了我的命运，因为当他站在航站楼时，他也站在了一个十字路口。有没有一个平行现实，戴夫没有接他，而是别人接了他，一个不是基督徒的人，我爸爸从未皈依，而我的生活也因此变得好多了？
I was born in Oklahoma and moved away when I was two. I have no memories of living there or of Dave. What was it about this place and these people that made my parents choose Christianity? If I went there myself, if I talked to Dave and the people who knew them, visited the places they spent time in, attended the church they worshipped at, and tried to imagine what their lives were like 35 years ago, maybe then I could finally understand why things went the way they did.
我出生在俄克拉荷马州，两岁时搬走了。我对在那里生活或关于戴夫没有任何记忆。这个地方和这些人到底有什么特别之处，让我父母选择了基督教？如果我自己去那里，如果我和戴夫以及认识他们的人交谈，访问他们花过时间的地方，参加他们崇拜的教堂，并试图想象35年前他们的生活是什么样的，也许那样我就能最终理解为什么事情会变成这样。
OK, I am standing in the Oklahoma City airport. I had this idea where I would stand where my dad stood, looking around for someone to pick him up. But I don't know exactly where that would be. Mostly I'm just tired and want to lay in a bed. I think I'll go do that.
好的，我正站在俄克拉荷马城机场。我有一个想法，我想站在我爸爸当年站的地方，环顾四周寻找接机的人。但我不知道具体在哪里。大部分时间我只是很累，想躺在床上。我想我应该去那样做。
Rolling my suitcase across the parking lot, I think about how my dad flew in from Beijing as an "alien," to use the official terminology, while I arrived from Pittsburgh as a US citizen. How my dad was at the mercy of strangers for transportation, while I have a license and rental car.
推着行李箱穿过停车场，我想到我爸爸当初是以“外星人”（官方术语）的身份从北京飞来的，而我却是以美国公民的身份从匹兹堡抵达的。我爸爸当时在交通方面受制于陌生人，而我有驾照和租来的车。
How I would now retrace the route my dad took from Oklahoma City to Norman, and how the one thing we share is a sense of exhaustion, of wanting nothing more than a warm bed in a private room at the end of a long day in a strange place.
我如何重新踏上我爸爸从俄克拉荷马城到诺曼的路线，以及我们唯一共同点就是一种疲惫感，在异国他乡漫长的一天结束后，除了在私密房间里拥有一张温暖的床之外别无他求。
(SUBJECT) THE FLAMING LIPS: 1, 2, 3, 4
（采访对象）烈焰红唇乐队：1, 2, 3, 4
["DO YOU REALIZE??" BY THE FLAMING LIPS]
【烈焰红唇乐队《你意识到吗？？》】
Do you remember what you saw looking out the window?
你还记得看着窗外看到了什么吗？
I think it's just highways. It's dark outside.
我想那只是高速公路。外面很黑。
Red Lobster, Chick-fil-A, McDonald's. I'm just naming chain restaurants here, all lit up in neon signs.
红龙虾餐厅、Chick-fil-A、麦当劳。我只是在列举连锁餐厅的名字，所有都在霓虹灯下闪烁。
Highway signs-- get off, get on, exit, I-35.
高速公路标志——驶出、驶入、出口、35号州际公路。
Continue on I-35 South for 13 miles.
继续沿35号州际公路南行13英里。
Here we go. University of Oklahoma is our exit.
我们走吧。俄克拉荷马大学就是我们的出口。
And then we went along, and we got to Norman. I think I was very tired. I fall asleep quickly.
然后我们继续前行，到了诺曼。我想我非常累。我很快就睡着了。
(SUBJECT) THE FLAMING LIPS: (SINGING) That everyone you know someday will--
（采访对象）烈焰红唇乐队：（唱歌）你认识的每个人总有一天会——
[CAR DOOR SHUTS]
【关车门声】
The next day, I go to my parents' first apartment. I just want to see it with my own eyes. The building is two stories and painted a pale yellow, with a big porch a guy is sitting on. All of a sudden--
第二天，我去了我父母的第一套公寓。我只是想亲眼看看它。那栋楼有两层，漆成了浅黄色，还有一个大门廊，一个人正坐在上面。突然间——
[SIREN]
【警报声】
I guess that's some sort of warning? Maybe like a tornado warning? Is there a tornado coming? No idea. Anyway, I'm going to do my parents' commute, walk to the old chemistry building that they used to stay at.
我猜那是什么警报？也许是龙卷风警报？有龙卷风要来吗？不知道。无论如何，我要重走我父母的通勤路线，步行到他们以前呆过的旧化学大楼。
It's very quiet, nobody. When you walk on the street, you even can hear your own footsteps and your own breathing. We came from Beijing and such big cities, so many people. Everywhere is crowd. All of a sudden, you went to a place just opposite. So you can imagine that kind of shocking [CHUCKLES] feeling.
非常安静，没有人。当你走在街上，甚至能听到自己的脚步声和呼吸声。我们来自北京这样的大城市，人那么多。到处都是拥挤的。突然间，你来到了一个完全相反的地方。所以你可以想象那种令人震惊的（轻笑）感觉。
This might be the chemistry building. This is the old chemistry building. It's called the chemistry building annex.
这可能就是化学大楼。这就是旧化学大楼。它被称为化学大楼附楼。
I kind of feel very lost and have no sense of being anchored to any spot because I feel I'm just parachute to the place in the middle of nowhere. I don't know anyone. You start with zero. I mean, you are on ground zero.
我感觉非常迷茫，没有任何地方感，因为我觉得我只是空降到了这个荒无人烟的地方。我不认识任何人。你从零开始。我的意思是，你在原点。
Three or four stories and faded yellow brick, some castle-like turrets on the top. Interesting. Some of the outside is pretty corroded now.
三四层楼高，褪色的黄色砖墙，顶部有一些像城堡一样的炮塔。有意思。外面的一些部分现在已经很腐蚀了。
When you said you just parachuted into this place and you started at zero, you had nothing, do you think that's why you relied so heavily on the church?
当你刚才说你只是空降到这个地方并且从零开始，你一无所有，你觉得这就是你如此依赖教会的原因吗？
I think so, because you all of a sudden lost your-- your don't have a gravity. You don't have a gravity. Life is so fragile. That's how I felt. This could be happening in a second, just turning upside down.
我想是这样，因为你突然失去了你的——你没有重心。你没有重心。生活是如此脆弱。我就是这种感觉。这可能在一秒钟内发生，只是天翻地覆。
I visit the campus library and find physical copies of my parents' PhD dissertations. My mom's is titled "Formation and Characterization of Anchored Polymer Coatings on Alumina." There's a Cheetos bag sandwiched between the front cover and first page. No idea why. I ask my mom about this later. Did you leave a Cheetos bag in your dissertation, maybe as some sort of message to future readers? She's like, what? No.
我参观了校园图书馆，找到了我父母博士论文的实体副本。我妈妈的论文标题是《氧化铝上锚定聚合物涂层的形成与表征》。封面和首页之间夹着一袋奇多。不知道为什么。我后来问了我妈。你在论文里留了一袋奇多，可能是给未来读者传达什么信息吗？她说，什么？没有。
In the acknowledgments, which is the only section I can understand, she writes, "I shall give all glory and honor to GOD," all caps. "HE," all caps, "is my strength." I throw away the Cheetos bag on my way out.
在致谢部分，这是我唯一能读懂的部分，她写道：“我将一切荣耀和尊贵归于上帝（GOD）”，全部大写。“他（HE）”，全部大写，“是我的力量。”我在出门时把那袋奇多扔了。
[PHONE DIALING]
【拨打电话声】
The first person I talk to in Oklahoma is Dave, the nice gentleman with the warm smile who took my dad in and brought him to Christ. Dave knew me as an infant and visited us in Philly, which I have no memory of. My parents always referred to him as my yeye, my grandfather, perhaps in place of the yeye in China I never met.
我在俄克拉荷马谈的第一个人是戴夫，那位带着温暖微笑的友善绅士，他收留了我爸爸，并将他引向了基督。戴夫在我婴儿时期就认识我，还在费城探望过我们，我对此没有记忆。我父母总是称他为“爷爷”，也许是为了代替我在中国从未谋面的那位爷爷。
This would probably be my first and only chance to talk to him, at least since I gained consciousness and the power of speech. I wanted to know, who is this man? How did he end up in charge of this Chinese ministry that changed the fate of my parents' lives-- and my life?
这可能是我第一次也是唯一一次和他谈话的机会，至少在我拥有意识和语言能力之后是这样。我想知道，这个人是谁？他是如何负责这个改变了我父母命运——以及我命运——的华人事工的？
Hello?
喂？
Good afternoon, Boen.
下午好，博恩。
Hi. Nice to finally talk with you. How are you?
嗨。很高兴最终能和你通话。你好吗？
Well, I'm well-- [CLEARS THROAT] excuse me-- for being 90 next February.
嗯，我很好——（清嗓子）抱歉——明年二月我就90岁了。
Oh, wow. You're OK with me recording this?
哦，哇。你介意我录音吗？
You're recording it?
你在录音？
Yeah, is that OK?
是的，可以吗？
That's OK.
可以。
All right.
好的。
But let me say this.
但让我说一句。
Sure.
请说。
I found that if you publicly identify somebody, the devil really can come in and try to take away their testimony. And I would just urge you that if you do write this, that's honoring to your mom and dad, but you don't want the devil jumping on them. So do you understand that?
我发现如果你公开指认某人，魔鬼真的会进来试图夺走他们的见证。我只是恳求你，如果你真的写了这些，那是在尊敬你的父母，但你不会想让魔鬼找上他们的。所以你明白吗？
I do, yeah.
我明白，是的。
The way I understand what Dave is saying here is that since I'm publicizing my parents' story, I need to make sure not to dishonor or slander them, because the devil is lying in wait. Dave worked as a campus minister in colleges across the US and the world, in Nebraska and Maryland and Nairobi, Kenya. But he spent the bulk of his career ministering to Chinese international students at OU, as the University of Oklahoma is confusingly nicknamed, starting in 1987, two years before my parents arrived.
我对戴夫这段话的理解是，因为我在宣传我父母的故事，我需要确保不羞辱或诽谤他们，因为魔鬼潜伏在侧。戴夫曾在美国和世界各地的大学担任校园传教士，在内布拉斯加州、马里兰州和肯尼亚内罗毕。但他的大部分职业生涯都在俄克拉荷马大学（OU，即俄克拉荷马大学的缩写，名字令人困惑）向中国留学生传教，始于1987年，在我父母抵达前两年。
Did you have any sort of prior knowledge of China or Chinese culture or the language or anything like that?
你对中国或中国文化或语言有任何预先的了解吗？
Well, [CLEARS THROAT] no. When the Chinese started coming over here from mainland China, they had never been in a church. They had never met a Christian. They had never seen a Bible. But they came over here, wanting to know our culture.
嗯，（清嗓子）没有。当中国人开始从中国大陆来到这里时，他们从未进过教堂。他们从未见过基督徒。他们从未见过圣经。但他们来到这里，想要了解我们的文化。
It sounded like he almost stumbled into this role. He saw a new population at OU, many of whom were already curious about Western culture and Christianity, and he was happy to oblige. It was clarifying for me to learn that Dave had been a missionary in Kenya. I've come to think of him as a sort of domestic missionary, serving people from outside the US, within the US.
听起来他几乎是偶然进入这个角色的。他在俄克拉荷马大学看到了一群新人，其中许多人已经对西方文化和基督教感到好奇，他很乐意帮忙。了解戴夫曾在肯尼亚做过传教士对我来说很清晰。我开始把他看作是一种本土传教士，在美国国内服务来自美国以外的人。
I think it's somewhere close to 450 Chinese-- closer, maybe, even to 500 during that time over the years, say. We didn't rush them. We didn't want them to become Christians to please us. But we would love them. We'd take them on trips. We'd have Bible study with them.
我想在那期间多年来有450名中国人——甚至接近500名。我们没有催促他们。我们不希望他们为了取悦我们而成为基督徒。但我们会爱他们。我们会带他们去旅行。我们会和他们一起学习圣经。
Among these acts of love were practical things, like picking my dad up from the airport. My mom came four months later. Dave picked her up as well. At that point, my dad was ready to convert. Dave and his wife came to my parents' apartment. My dad got on his knees, prayed to accept Jesus into his heart.
这些爱心行为中包括一些实际的事情，比如从机场接我爸爸。我妈妈四个月后来了。戴夫也接了她。那时，我爸爸已经准备好皈依了。戴夫和他的妻子来到我父母的公寓。我爸爸跪下，祈祷将耶稣接到他心里。
And then your dad looked up and smiled. And he said, this wasn't as hard as I thought it would be. [CHUCKLES] And he was really happy. And I looked over at your mom, and she was crying. And I said, what's the matter? And she said, well, you're a Christian, and now my husband's a Christian, but I'm the only one that's not a Christian.
然后你爸爸抬起头笑了。他说，这并不像我想象的那么难。（轻笑）他真的很高兴。我看向你妈妈，她在哭。我说，怎么了？她说，嗯，你是基督徒，现在我丈夫也是基督徒，但我却是唯一不是基督徒的人。
I just feel now it seems there's a line between me and Daddy. And so that make me mixed feeling, really mixed feeling.
我现在觉得我和爸爸之间有一道鸿沟。所以这让我心情很复杂，真的很复杂。
You felt like there was a line, like a dividing line between you and Dad at that moment?
你觉得那一刻你和爸爸之间有一道界线，一道分界线？
Yeah, because he became a child of God. I'm not yet. So it feels like we are now in a different path.
是的，因为他成了上帝的孩子。我还不是。所以感觉我们现在走上了不同的道路。
And I said, well, be patient. We'll get to that. But you need to know what it's all about first. [CHUCKLES] Oh, I loved your parents.
我说，嗯，要有耐心。我们会达到那一点的。但你首先需要了解它是关于什么的。（轻笑）哦，我爱你的父母。
How long after my dad came to Christ until my mom came to Christ as well?
我爸爸皈依基督后多久，我妈妈也皈依了？
Oh, it was only maybe a month or two or three weeks.
哦，可能只有一个月或两三周。
Over the phone, I didn't have the courage to tell this kindly old man who led my parents to the path of Christianity, who then raised me on that path, that I rejected all of that and that I'm still recovering. But then, when I go to him in person, I resolve to tell him the full truth. Dave is in an assisted living facility now. In the lobby, I meet his son and daughter-in-law, who had asked that I not record the conversation.
在电话里，我没有勇气告诉这位引领我父母走上基督教道路、随后又以此路径抚养我长大的仁慈老人，我拒绝了所有这一切，而且我至今仍在康复中。但后来，当我亲自去见他时，我下定决心告诉他全部真相。戴夫现在在辅助生活设施中。在大堂里，我见到了他的儿子和儿媳，他们要求我不要录音。
Dave had fallen recently and broken a vertebrae. He sits in an armchair in his room and wears a neck brace. If he sneezes or laughs too hard, he can hurt himself. After a softball question, I forced myself to come clean. I'm no longer Christian. How does he feel about people he tried to lead to Christ who either didn't believe or later left?
戴夫最近摔倒，摔断了一块椎骨。他坐在房间里的扶手椅上，戴着颈托。如果他打喷嚏或笑得太厉害，他可能会伤害自己。在问了一个简单问题后，我强迫自己坦白。我不再是基督徒了。他怎么看待那些他试图引领向基督却要么不相信要么后来离开的人？
Dave smiles. He asks if I'd heard the story of the prodigal son. It's a classic, one of Jesus's most famous parables, where a failson disobeys his dad and later returns to him, penitent and willing to accept any punishment. But instead, his dad forgives him and welcomes him home. Dave then explains that he has a daughter who left the church. In high school, she angrily confronted Dave with tears in her eyes and told him, Dad, please apologize to me for being a Christian.
戴夫微笑了。他问我是否听过浪子回头的那个故事。这是一个经典，耶稣最著名的比喻之一，一个败家子违背了他的父亲，后来又回到他身边，悔改并愿意接受任何惩罚。但相反，他的父亲原谅了他并欢迎他回家。戴夫随后解释说，他有一个离开了教会的女儿。在高中时，她含着泪愤怒地质问戴夫，对他说，爸爸，请为成为一名基督徒向我道歉。
I think I understand what she meant by that. It's a way of saying, apologize for making this decision for me, for raising me with this belief I didn't choose and that I don't agree with. In a sense, I'm asking him the same thing-- Yeye, why did you convert my parents?
我想我明白她那句话的意思。这是一种表达方式，意思是，为替我做这个决定道歉，为用这种我没有选择且我不同意的信仰抚养我道歉。某种意义上，我也在问他同样的问题——爷爷，你为什么要让我父母皈依？
His daughter left the faith. Dave didn't try to convince her of anything, just kept loving her and praying for her. And after 20 years, she, like the prodigal son, returned to the faith and to her father. These days, she visits him every week in the assisted living facility.
他的女儿离开了信仰。戴夫没有试图说服她任何事情，只是继续爱她、为她祈祷。20年后，她像浪子一样回到了信仰，回到了父亲身边。这些天，她每周都会去辅助生活设施看望他。
Dave emphasizes again that he never forced anyone to believe anything, that if someone chooses to reject Christianity, they need to be loved, whatever their decision is. But he also tells me, there will be nobody going to hell who didn't have an opportunity to accept Christ. He says it in a way that isn't angry or spiteful-- just sad, almost kind.
戴夫再次强调他从未强迫任何人相信任何事情，如果有人选择拒绝基督教，他们需要被爱，无论他们的决定是什么。但他也告诉我，没有机会接受基督的人是不会下地狱的。他说这话时并不愤怒或恶毒——只是悲伤，甚至有点仁慈。
It's getting late. Dave needs to take his medication. We stand up. I love you, he tells me. Give my love to your parents. We hug. And I get it. I get why my parents converted. This man is filled with so much love and gives it so freely-- to my parents, to me, to all of the people he picked up from the airport and fed and sheltered and helped get on their feet.
天色已晚。戴夫需要服药。我们站起来。我爱你，他告诉我。替我问候你的父母。我们拥抱。我明白了。我明白了为什么我父母会皈依。这个人充满了如此多的爱，并且如此慷慨地给予——给我的父母，给我，给所有他从机场接走、提供食物、住所并帮助他们站稳脚跟的人。
Where does his love come from? In the moment, I'm convinced that it must be something beyond what any human is capable of. It must come from God. On the receiving end of his unconditional love, I consider being the prodigal son. For the briefest flash of a moment, I consider returning.
他的爱来自哪里？那一刻，我确信它一定超出了任何人类的能力。它一定来自上帝。在他无条件的爱的接受端，我考虑成为那个浪子。有那么短暂的一闪念，我考虑回归。
Can I pray for you?
我可以为你祷告吗？
When we were on the phone, this is how Dave ended the call. I didn't feel like I could say no. I didn't want to disappoint my white grandpa.
当我们通电话时，戴夫就是这样结束通话的。我觉得我无法拒绝。我不想让我的白人爷爷失望。
Sure.
当然。
OK. Lord, thank you for this wonderful invention, the phone, that Boen and me may join our hearts at the throne of grace. And Lord, I just want to thank you for Boen calling. And I pray that, for the rest of his life, that he will walk with you till he draws his last breath. In Christ's name, Amen.
好的。主啊，感谢你发明了电话这个奇妙的东西，让博恩和我可以在恩典的宝座前联结我们的心灵。主啊，我只想感谢博恩打来电话。我祈求在余生中，他都能与你同行，直到他呼出最后一口气。奉基督的名，阿门。
Amen.
阿门。
I talked to Dave on Saturday night. Come Sunday, it's obvious where I have to go.
我在周六晚上和戴夫谈过。到了周日，显而易见我必须去哪里。
Quick voice memo, because I'm already late, but I'm at the church. Kind of tired. Woke up at 8:30. Stayed up too late last night. Already late, but I'm going to go to this Mandarin Sunday school. We'll see how it goes.
快速语音备忘录，因为我已经迟到了，但我现在在教堂。有点累。8:30醒的。昨晚熬得太晚了。已经迟到了，但我还是要去这个中文主日学。我们看看会怎么样。
This is the church where Dave led the Chinese fellowship, the one my parents attended and that I attended as an infant until we moved away when I was two. What did this place mean to them? These are people who had zero experience with organized religion. What do they get from going?
这就是戴夫领导华人团契的教堂，我父母曾经参加的那个，我婴儿时期也参加过，直到我们两岁时搬走。这个地方对他们意味着什么？这些人对组织化宗教毫无经验。他们从去那里得到了什么？
The Chinese Fellowship is now run by seven people, seven Daves, in other words, three of whom are Chinese and four of whom are white. I spoke to one of the new white Daves over the phone, who told me that I could record the service. But a few days later, while I was cooking butternut squash risotto, he called again and told me he had found a podcast called Jesus Wept.
华人团契现在由七个人运营，换句话说，有七个“戴夫”，其中三人是华人，四人是白人。我在电话里和其中一位新的白人“戴夫”交谈过，他告诉我我可以录制仪式。但几天后，当我正在煮奶油南瓜烩饭时，他又打来电话，告诉我他发现了一个叫《耶稣哭了》（Jesus Wept）的播客。
[JESUS WEPT THEME MUSIC]
【《耶稣哭了》主题曲】
Jesus Wept is a podcast my fiancée Grace and I make, where we analyze and, to be honest, make fun of various topics related to evangelical Christianity. We process our respective religious traumas through humor. In the most recent episode, I went to a Chinese church and recorded the service.
《耶稣哭了》是我和未婚妻格蕾丝制作的播客，我们在其中分析，老实说，是嘲笑各种与福音派基督教相关的话题。我们通过幽默来处理各自的宗教创伤。在最近的一集中，我去了华人教堂并录制了仪式。
Afterwards, Grace and I critiqued the speakers and-- again, to be honest-- made fun of them. I told Grace about how one of the speakers said that because Paul writes that women shouldn't have authority over men, she won't teach men in the church.
事后，我和格蕾丝批评了演讲者，而且——还是老实说——嘲笑了他们。我告诉格蕾丝其中一位演讲者是如何说，因为保罗写道女性不应在男性之上拥有权力，所以她不会在教会里教导男性。
So then, basically, she is like, well, in the church, I will teach women, I will teach children, but I will not teach men, except in specific circumstances.
所以，基本上，她说，嗯，在教会里，我会教导妇女，我会教导孩子，但我不会教导男人，除非在特定情况下。
Like what?
比如什么？
I don't know, but--
我不知道，但是——
How to change a diaper?
比如怎么换尿布？
[CHUCKLES] Maybe. Or--
（轻笑）也许吧。或者——
Doesn't she have a fucking PhD?
她难道没有博士学位吗？
She has a master's in divinity, yeah--
她有神学硕士学位，是的——
Oh.
哦。
--from the seminary.
——来自神学院。
But she can't teach?
但她不能教书？
Yeah. I don't know.
是的。我不知道。
It's an MRS Div.
这大概是MRS Div学位（暗讽女性去神学院只为找对象）。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
New Dave tells me over the phone that after listening to the podcast, he's changed his mind and won't allow me to record anything in Norman, which is reasonable. I recorded a church service and made fun of it, and he doesn't want me to do the same thing to his church. In the podcast, I talk about how I don't believe in God.
新戴夫在电话里告诉我，听了播客后，他改变了主意，不允许我在诺曼录制任何东西，这是合理的。我录制了一场教会仪式并嘲笑了它，他不希望我对他自己的教会做同样的事情。在播客中，我谈到了我不相信上帝。
And as we wrap up the conversation, New Dave says he needs my word that I won't record anything. He says, I know you don't believe in God, but there must be something you can base your word on, like your Chinese heritage--
当我们结束对话时，新戴夫说他需要我的承诺，我不会录制任何东西。他说，我知道你不相信上帝，但你总得有些东西作为你的信誉基础，比如你的华人血统——
[ORIENTAL RIFF]
【东方音乐片段】
--which is kind of a weird thing to say. But I'm like, sure, you have my word. See you Sunday.
——这话说得很奇怪。但我说，没问题，你得到我的承诺了。周日见。
When I enter the church, New Dave is waiting in the lobby. I shake his hand and tell him I'm not recording-- that was a royalty-free sound effect from freesound.org-- although I do have the pink notebook I'd bought from Target for $3. We walk past an armed guard to the gymnasium, where the Mandarin Sunday school is held. It seems notable that the Mandarin Sunday school isn't in a dedicated classroom, but an echoey gym with a basketball court.
当我进入教堂时，新戴夫在大厅等着。我握了握他的手，告诉他我没录音——那只是来自freesound.org的免版税音效——虽然我确实带着我从Target花3美元买的粉色笔记本。我们经过一名武装警卫进入体育馆，那是举办中文主日学的地方。值得注意的是，中文主日学不在专门的教室里，而是在一个有篮球场、回声很大体育馆里。
New Dave introduces me to a group of Chinese immigrants sitting around a folding table. They ask if I can speak Chinese. I say I can understand it OK, but not speak it that well. New Dave is like, ah, there's that phrase, ABC.
新戴夫把我介绍给坐在折叠桌旁的一群中国移民。他们问我会不会说中文。我说我能听懂，但说得不太好。新戴夫说，啊，就是那个词，ABC。
[ORIENTAL RIFF]
【东方音乐片段】
And I'm like, yep, that's me, American Born Chinese. As a side note, I really hate the phrase ABC. Just call me Chinese-American. Anyway, New Dave says that since he can't speak Mandarin, he's going to leave us to it. It's nice to be away from white people, at least for a little bit, to talk among ourselves in the language I associate with family, home, love.
我说，是的，就是我，美籍华人（American Born Chinese）。顺便提一下，我真的很讨厌ABC这个词。直接叫我华裔美国人就行了。无论如何，新戴夫说既然他不会说普通话，就把我们留在这里了。能暂时离开白人，用我与家庭、家、爱联系在一起的语言与同胞交谈，感觉真好。
My parents must have really craved that when they first came here. Where else could they find a Chinese community in a small town in Oklahoma? Someone later tells me that this church is usually the first stop for new Chinese immigrants. People from church are willing to give rides to the supermarket, furniture for apartments, help with taxes, and all sorts of essential services. My mom still uses a set of bowls that Dave got for her.
我父母刚来这里时一定真的很渴望这一点。在俄克拉荷马州的一个小镇上，他们还能去哪儿找华人社区？后来有人告诉我，这个教堂通常是中国新移民的第一站。教会的人愿意提供去超市的搭车、公寓的家具、报税帮助，以及各种基本服务。我妈妈现在还在用戴夫给她的一套碗。
[PIANO PLAYING]
【钢琴演奏】
When the service begins, we sing hymns in Mandarin. Again, this is not a recording from Oklahoma. It's YouTube. The speaker, an older white guy, delivers the sermon in English. And like most sermons, it's boring. I picture my parents in these same seats, praying the same prayers, singing the same songs that I would grow up singing.
仪式开始时，我们用中文唱赞美诗。同样，这不是在俄克拉荷马州的录音，是YouTube上的。演讲者，一个年长的白人，用英语讲道。像大多数讲道一样，很无聊。我想象我父母也坐在这些座位上，祈祷着同样的祷告，唱着我长大后会唱的同样的歌。
[SINGING IN MANDARIN]
【用中文演唱】
Boen Wang. Coming up, Boen flies home and considers the question-- maybe it wasn't Christianity that messed him up as a kid. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
博恩·王。接下来，博恩飞回家，思考这个问题——也许小时候让他感到崩溃的不是基督教。稍后在我们的节目继续时，从芝加哥公共广播电台为您播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Children of Dave, Boen Wang's pilgrimage to finally understand why his parents decided to become Christians when they arrived in America. We pick up our story where we left off before the break.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《戴夫的孩子们》，博恩·王前往去最终理解他父母为何在抵达美国后决定成为基督徒。我们从中断的地方继续我们的故事。
When I fly home to Pittsburgh and tell Grace about going to my parents' church and meeting Dave, they point out that maybe I'm just blaming Christianity for my own problems. Maybe Christianity is just my excuse to hate myself. It gave my self-loathing a shape and structure, but it isn't the root cause. Maybe I would have hated myself no matter what.
当我飞回匹兹堡，把去父母教堂见到戴夫的事情告诉格蕾丝时，他们指出，也许我只是把基督教当成了自己问题的替罪羊。也许基督教只是我恨自己的借口。它赋予了我自我厌恶以形状和结构，但它并不是根本原因。也许无论如何我都会恨自己。
Maybe it doesn't matter what path my dad chose at that crossroads in the Oklahoma City airport. If he never met Dave and never believed, maybe I'd still have the same self-loathing. If I grew up communist like my parents, maybe I'd be like, ugh, I'm such a bourgeois, capitalist, worthless piece of shit. I need to write another self-criticism and do another struggle session.
也许我爸爸在俄克拉荷马城机场的那个十字路口选择哪条路并不重要。如果他从未遇到戴夫，从未有信仰，也许我仍然会有同样的自我厌恶。如果我和我父母一样是在共产主义环境下长大，也许我会想，呃，我真是一个资产阶级、资本主义的一文不值的废物。我得写另一份自我批评，参加另一场批斗大会。
Thankfully, I can answer the question of whether I'd hate myself if I hadn't been raised Christian by comparing myself with my high school friend, Andrew. Andrew grew up in the same suburb of Philly as me. His parents are highly-educated Chinese immigrants. We attended the same school district and have the same circle of friends. But he was raised by atheist parents who were never interested in Christianity or church.
值得庆幸的是，我可以回答关于如果我不是在基督教环境下长大是否会恨自己这个问题，方法是将自己与高中朋友安德鲁进行比较。安德鲁和我是在费城的同一个郊区长大的。他的父母是受过高等教育的中国移民。我们上了同一个学区，有同一个朋友圈。但他是由对他从未表现出对基督教或教堂感兴趣的无神论父母抚养长大的。
I asked my mom one time. I was like, have you ever been to church? And she was like, uh, yeah, of course we've been to church. And then what she really meant was that we walked into a church one time and walked out.
有一次我问我妈妈。我说，你有没有去过教堂？她说，呃，当然，我们当然去过教堂。其实她的意思是，我们有一次走进过教堂，然后又走出来了。
So I sit Andrew down and tell him that I want to conduct a science experiment.
所以我让安德鲁坐下，告诉他我想做一个科学实验。
Where you're the atheist control group, and I am the ex-Christian test subject.
我想，通过这个科学实验，也许平衡我们、使我们具有可比性的主要因素是第二代移民的成长环境。
OK, I understand that we have a sample size of two, but just humor me. Andrew has lived the life I always imagined-- a life without church or youth group or Bible study or retreats near Lancaster, out in Amish country. And so my question is, in this alternate atheist reality that Andrew was raised in, does he also struggle with self-loathing? Does he not like himself?
好的，我知道我们的样本量是两个，但就陪我玩玩吧。安德鲁过着我一直想象的生活——没有教堂、青年团契、圣经研习班或在兰开斯特阿米什地区附近的静修会的生活。所以我的问题是，在安德鲁这种无神论现实环境下，他也和自我厌恶作斗争吗？他不喜欢自己吗？
I don't like myself.
我不喜欢自己。
OK, all right. Well, fine. But does he dislike himself the same amount as I do, in the same way? Does he do the thing where I ask someone endless follow-up questions, and if they ask me something, I do verbal jujitsu and redirect it back to them, because I hate talking about myself, because I hate myself?
好的，好吧。但是，他讨厌自己的程度和我一样吗？方式一样吗？他会做我那种询问别人没完没了的后续问题，如果他们问我什么，我就用语言柔道重定向回去的事吗？因为我讨厌谈论自己，因为我讨厌自己。
So familiar. I could say those exact same words. And that's exactly what I do.
太熟悉了。我能说出完全相同的话。这正是我的做法。
Like, if Andrew is meeting one of his colleagues for the first time, he'll be like--
比如，如果安德鲁第一次见他的同事，他会说——
What department are you in? How long have you been in the university for? What kind of research are you doing? What's your lab like? Who are you working with?
你是哪个部门的？你在大学里多久了？你在做什么研究？你的实验室怎么样？你和谁一起工作？
And if someone asks Andrew a question like what his research is, he'll be like--
如果有人问安德鲁一个问题，比如他的研究是什么，他会说——
Oh, I work in biostats. And then I just call it a day. I just make sure as hard as possible that they don't ask me any questions. I don't want to talk about it.
哦，我在生物统计部门工作。然后我今天就到此为止。我只是尽我所能确保他们不问我任何问题。我不想谈论它。
Andrew didn't even have to grow up Christian to hate himself and for his self-hatred to manifest in the exact same way. So where is this coming from? Andrew doesn't believe in sin or God. Why do we hate ourselves, even though we were raised with such different beliefs? Well, Andrew thinks the answer might be right in front of us.
安德鲁甚至不需要在基督教环境下长大就会恨自己，而且这种自我憎恨会以同样的方式表现出来。那么这来自哪里？安德鲁不相信罪或上帝。为什么我们恨自己，即使我们是在如此不同的信仰下长大的？好吧，安德鲁认为答案可能就在我们面前。
I wonder, with this science experiment, maybe the main thing that's balancing us, that makes us comparable, is a second generation upbringing.
我很好奇，通过这个科学实验，也许让我们达到平衡、使我们具有可比性的主要因素，是第二代教养。
Our parents are from a very specific cohort of people who grew up during the Cultural Revolution, went to the best colleges in China, went abroad to get STEM PhDs, and got well-paying jobs in academia and pharmaceuticals and biomedicine.
我们的父母是一群非常特定的人，他们在文化大革命期间长大，上了中国最好的大学，出国攻读STEM博士学位，并在学术界、制药和生物医学领域获得了高薪工作。
And I think that, to me, makes me always kind of feel inadequate in a way, right? Like, I'll never be able to do that. I'll never be able to achieve that rags-to-riches kind of story, because I was never in rags. [CHUCKLES] My parents were the ones that struggled through that.
我觉得这让我一直感到自己不够好，对吧？就像，我永远做不到那种程度。我永远无法实现那种从贫民窟到富翁的故事，因为我从未在贫民窟待过。（轻笑）我父母才是那个熬过艰苦日子的人。
So we're more or less on the same page when it comes to self-loathing. But what about the shame I feel about sex and sexuality? What about my inability to talk about the horny Zendaya tennis movie with Grace? Does Andrew feel that same immense shame?
所以说到自我厌恶，我们基本在同一个频道上。但我对性和性行为感到的羞耻感呢？我无法和格蕾丝谈论那部性感的赞达亚网球电影怎么办？安德鲁也感到那种巨大的羞耻吗？
So, then, how did you feel about sex, morally?
那么，你在道德上是怎么看待性的？
There's nothing wrong with it. I think this is also somewhat funny that a lot of Christians will marry early, right? Because they have to marry before they have sex. But for people that don't grow up Christian, the consensual act of sex is just not a problem.
这没什么问题。我觉得很有趣的是，很多基督徒会早婚，对吧？因为他们必须在性交前结婚。但对于那些不是在基督教环境下长大的人来说，基于同意的性行为根本不是问题。
Andrew started dating when he was 15. I didn't start until a decade later. When we tried to isolate the effect Christianity had on me, that's the word we kept returning to-- shame. The shame I feel about having a body, about being a wretched sinner in need of redemption-- Andrew feels none of that. The shame goes to my very core in a way that Andrew can't relate to. I told him about how, even today, when I remember something embarrassing I said, or did years ago--
安德鲁15岁就开始约会了。我直到十年后才开始。当我们试图孤立基督教对我产生的影响时，我们不断回到的词就是——羞耻。我因为拥有一个身体而感到的羞耻，因为是一个需要救赎的可怜罪人而感到的羞耻——安德鲁一点都没有。这种羞耻感深入我的骨髓，是安德鲁无法感同身受的。我告诉他，即使是今天，当我想起我几年前说过或做过的尴尬事情时——
I'll still say out loud to myself, because it's such a reflex at this point, of, like, oh, I hate myself. I should kill myself. Like, I verbalize that.
我还是会大声对自己说，因为这已经成为了一种反射，比如，哦，我恨我自己。我应该自杀。我会把它表达出来。
You still say that?
你还这么说？
Yeah. You act surprised. Have you ever done this? Have you ever said-- no? No?
是的。你看起来很惊讶。你做过这个吗？你有没有说——没有？没有？
But I-- yeah, that's intense, man. That's intense reflex. [LAUGHS] I don't have that reflex.
但我——是的，那很激烈，伙计。那是非常强烈的反射。（笑）我没有那种反射。
Are you telling me that you've never said out loud to yourself, I hate myself. I want to kill myself. You never said that, Andrew?
你是说你从未大声对自己说，我恨我自己。我想自杀。你从来没说过，安德鲁？
I have never said that. That's the Christian difference, man.
我从来没说过。这就是基督教的区别，伙计。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
That's the Christian difference.
这就是基督教的区别。
Yeah.
是的。
[PIANO COVER OF "DO YOU REALIZE??"]
【《你意识到吗？？》钢琴版】
The Christian difference is a belief that my existence is fundamentally wrong. The Christian difference is a need to punish myself for my existence. I don't regret being raised Christian. I wouldn't be who I am today otherwise. And I'm incredibly grateful for everything my parents have done for me.
基督教的区别在于一种信念，即我的存在从根本上就是错误的。基督教的区别在于需要因为我的存在而惩罚自己。我不后悔被抚养在基督教环境下。否则，我也不会成为今天的我。我无比感激我父母为我所做的一切。
But on this one aspect, I know I would have experienced less pain if my dad had stood at that crossroads in the Oklahoma City airport and chosen a different path. I never told my parents about the damage Christianity caused me. I didn't want to make them feel bad or think I was blaming them. I didn't want to seem ungrateful. But now, it's what I finally decide to do. At this point, it's the only thing I can do.
但在这一个方面，我知道如果我爸爸在俄克拉荷马城机场的那个十字路口选择了另一条路，我会经历更少的痛苦。我从未告诉父母基督教给我造成的伤害。我不想让他们感到难过，也不想让他们认为我在责怪他们。我不想显得不知感恩。但现在，这是我最终决定要做的。在这一点上，这是我唯一能做的。
I was actually damaged by going to church and being raised in church. Does that make sense? Do you understand that?
我实际上因为去教堂和在教堂长大而受到了伤害。这说得通吗？你明白吗？
It's heartbreaking to realize. And of course, whatever happened in the past, it's gone. It's the past, right? But I just feel that we could have done better. We could have done better.
意识到这一点真的很令人心碎。当然，无论过去发生了什么，都过去了。那是过去，对吧？但我只是觉得我们本来可以做得更好。我们本来可以做得更好的。
Really? Why do you feel that way?
真的吗？你为什么会有这种感觉？
Because we really didn't check on how you received the information. We didn't really talk to you that much. And we just receive automatically without checking. And we just blindly believe everything that church teaches is right.
因为我们确实没有检查你接收信息的方式。我们并没有真正和你多交流。我们只是自动接受了，没有去核实。我们盲目相信教堂教导的一切都是对的。
You felt like you blindly believed?
你觉得你盲目相信了？
Yes, because-- I mean that blindly not believe what church is teaching-- the way they teach. Yeah.
是的，因为——我是说那种盲目相信教堂教导的东西——他们教导的方式。是的。
So then do you have any regrets, then, about raising me and sister in the church?
那么，你对在教堂抚养我和姐姐这件事有遗憾吗？
Yes, but after you said that to me. Yeah, I do feel. I do feel I didn't really pay too much attention to how they taught you, how they taught you, and how that has print on you and how that manifest in your overall well-being. Yeah, I do feel very sorry.
有，但在你对我说了那些话之后。是的，我有。我真的觉得我没有太注意他们是怎么教你的，怎么教导你的，以及这对你有什么影响，它如何体现在你的整体健康上。是的，我感到非常抱歉。
I was not expecting this. I always thought my mom and dad were a united front, true believers. When I first interviewed my mom about converting to Christianity, she described it as this happy moment when she joined my dad in the same belief.
我没料到会这样。我一直以为我的父母是一个统一战线，真正的信徒。当我第一次采访我母亲关于皈依基督教的事时，她将其描述为她加入我父亲拥有相同信仰的幸福时刻。
I feel we are same people now. [LAUGHS] We are same people. We are equal footing. We are children of God.
我觉得我们现在是同类人了。（笑）我们是同类人。我们处于平等的地位。我们是上帝的孩子。
But when I came back to her a few months later--
但几个月后我再次去找她——
Actually, I was thinking that the time I decided to become a Christian, I think I'm very premature to make my decision because I really do not know much, and I just got here. And the things has been changed dramatically for me in every aspect. And I don't really have that kind of self-confidence to my own belief. So I feel there are a lot of outside factors.
实际上，我在想我决定成为基督徒的那段时间，我觉得自己做决定太草率了，因为我真的不太了解，我刚到这里。对我来说，各方面的事情都发生了巨大的变化。我对自己信仰的自信心并不强。所以我感觉有很多外部因素。
My mom wants to be clear about this here on the radio. She will always be thankful to the people from church who helped her get on her feet, in the same way that I want to be clear that I'll always be thankful to my parents. But looking back, my mom sees that the kindness of Christians can be transactional. We give you free stuff, and in return, you go to church.
我妈妈想在广播里把这一点说清楚。她将永远感谢那些帮助她站稳脚跟的教会人士，正如我也想说清楚，我将永远感谢我的父母。但回顾过去，我妈妈看出基督徒的仁慈可能是有交易性质的。我们给你免费的东西，作为交换，你去教堂。
This is how church tries to get those people to become believers. No, if you really believe, you are not bribing that person to become a believer. That's my point.
这就是教会试图让人们成为信徒的方式。不，如果你真的相信，你就不会贿赂那个人成为信徒。这就是我的观点。
You think it's bribery?
你认为这是贿赂？
Yeah, I think that's a bribery.
是的，我认为这是贿赂。
That's a strong word, Mom.
这是一个严厉的词，妈妈。
Yeah, I do feel-- no, I do feel that's a bribery. You bribe those people. You give them free lunch, free ride, free stuff. [LAUGHS] Yeah.
是的，我确实感到——不，我确实觉得那是贿赂。你贿赂那些人。你给他们免费午餐，免费搭车，免费的东西。（笑）是的。
Well, how about all the free stuff that you and Dad got when you were first in Oklahoma?
那么你和爸爸刚到俄克拉荷马州时得到的那些免费的东西呢？
I didn't really think about that at the moment. Now I feel, yeah.
那一刻我真的没想那么多。现在我感觉，是的。
Over the years, my mom's been really hurt by people from church. She had raised questions about the Bible. Like, if God created everything, why did He also create Satan? Why would He allow Satan to tempt Eve into eating the forbidden fruit? Why would He even create forbidden fruit in the first place? No one at church would ever fully engage with her. They'd give her surface-level platitudes that never satisfied her.
多年来，我母亲一直被教会里的人伤害。她曾提出关于圣经的问题。比如，如果上帝创造了一切，为什么祂也创造了撒旦？为什么祂要允许撒旦引诱夏娃吃禁果？为什么祂一开始要创造禁果？教会里没有人能完全理解她。他们给了她永远不能满足她的平庸说辞。
There was also a period when she was depressed. I remember coming home from school and seeing my mom lying on the couch with the lights turned off and the curtains closed. My mom tells me that while some people at church helped her in this moment, others weren't so kind, and some actually seemed happy that she was suffering.
还有一段时间她很抑郁。我记得放学回家，看到我妈妈关着灯、拉着窗帘躺在沙发上。我妈妈告诉我，虽然教会里有些人在这时帮助了她，但其他人并不那么友善，有些人甚至似乎很高兴她受苦。
I think now they believe-- they already labeled me as a non-believer. [LAUGHS]
我想现在他们相信——他们已经给我贴上了“非信徒”的标签。（笑）
Wait, really?
等等，真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
At church?
在教堂里？
Yeah.
是的。
Why do they think that you're a non-believer?
为什么他们认为你是非信徒？
Because I don't go to church anymore. I do not participate in any kind of church activities.
因为我不去教堂了。我不参加任何形式的教堂活动。
Why did you stop participating?
你为什么停止参加？
Because I don't get anything from participating in all those activities. And if I ask them questions, they give me standard answers. I just feel I'm in a circle, [LAUGHS] not going anywhere. I don't really get enriched or enlightened by doing all those activities.
因为我从参加那些活动中得不到任何东西。如果我问他们问题，他们只给标准答案。我只是觉得我在一个圈子里（笑），没有任何进展。我并没有因为做所有这些活动而感到充实或开明。
She hasn't been there since the pandemic shut everything down and is much happier for it. But as my mom withdrew from church, my dad got even more involved. He became a deacon and spent more and more time at church functions and less and less time at home with his family. If someone needed a ride to the supermarket, he would do it. If someone needed a ride to the airport, he would do it. My mom was not happy about this.
自疫情关闭一切以来她就没再去过那里，对此她感到更快乐。但随着我妈妈退出教会，我爸爸却参与得更深了。他成为了执事，花在教会活动上的时间越来越多，在家里陪伴家人的时间越来越少。如果有人需要去超市的搭车，他会做。如果有人需要去机场的搭车，他会做。我妈妈对此很不高兴。
I feel he's like a robot. He just does it automatically whenever someone-- from all directions, to the point that he completely crazy. So that is time I think the church can destroy a family. Church can really destroy a family because when you are not really thinking on the same level, at the same level, on the same page, and you kind of just go apart.
我觉得他就像个机器人。只要有人从四面八方提出要求，他就自动去做，直到他完全疯了。所以那时我觉得教会可以摧毁一个家庭。教会真的可以摧毁一个家庭，因为当你不在同一个层次、不在同一个层面、不在同一个频道思考时，你们就会分崩离析。
So do you feel like church almost destroyed our family?
所以你觉得教会差点摧毁了我们的家庭？
To the point.
到了那种地步。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. I was really, really upset at one point.
是的。有一次我真的、真的非常生气。
So my mom finally put her foot down and gave my dad an ultimatum.
所以我妈妈最终坚持立场，给了我爸爸最后通牒。
And I told Dad, you quit your deacon now. Otherwise, we are not going to have a same life under the same roof. So Daddy sent a letter to church that he's going to resign.
我告诉爸爸，你现在辞掉执事。否则，我们将无法在同一个屋檐下生活。所以爸爸寄了一封信给教会，说他要辞职。
It was almost comforting, realizing I wasn't the odd one out in my family. I thought I was the only one who was damaged by Christianity and who left the church. I thought it was me against them, but it turns out that my mom was actually on my side this whole time. Who knew?
意识到我不是家里唯一被边缘化的人，这甚至让人感到安慰。我以为我是唯一一个被基督教伤害并离开教会的人。我以为是我对抗他们，但结果证明我妈妈一直站在我这一边。谁能想到呢？
I wasn't surprised that my dad gave in to my mom, though. When it comes down to it, he puts family first. I asked him once if he ever had any regrets, and he told me the story about how, when my sister was a baby, he discovered that she had torn up an important piece of mail. My dad yelled at her and made her cry, and then he thought to himself, why did I do that? She's just a baby. She doesn't understand what she's doing. And he remembered that moment forever.
不过，我不惊讶我爸爸向我妈妈妥协了。归根结底，他把家庭放在第一位。有一次我问他是否有过任何遗憾，他告诉我一个故事，在我姐姐还是婴儿时，他发现她撕碎了一封重要的邮件。我爸爸对她大喊大叫，让她哭了起来，然后他对自己想，我为什么要那样做？她只是个婴儿。她不明白自己在做什么。他永远记得那一刻。
So he's always been a kind, thoughtful, reflective person who wants the best for us. He's also always been a true believer, going back to the very beginning.
所以他一直是一个善良、体贴、善于反思的人，希望我们最好。他一直也是一个真正的信徒，追溯到最初的时候。
[PROTESTERS SINGING INTERNATIONALE]
【抗议者唱《国际歌》】
June 1989.
1989年6月。
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
【欢呼，掌声】
My dad has been accepted to the University of Oklahoma. He applies for his passport and visa so that he can leave Beijing. On the evening of June 3, my parents watched the news on their landlord's TV since they don't have one of their own.
我爸爸被俄克拉荷马大学录取了。他申请护照和签证，以便离开北京。6月3日晚上，我的父母在房东的电视上看新闻，因为他们自己没有电视。
There's a TV announcement say don't go to Tiananmen Square.
电视广播说不要去天安门广场。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
【讲普通话】
They go to bed.
他们上床睡觉了。
In the middle of the night, we heard some gunshots.
半夜，我们听到了枪声。
And on the morning of June 4, they wake up.
在6月4日早上，他们醒来了。
In the morning, we were planning to visit a friend, to bicycle to her home. On the way, we saw a lot of buses. They were turned around and blocked the road. And also, a lot of huge trucks, like armored vehicles, just parked along the highways, blocking the road.
早上，我们计划拜访一个朋友，骑自行车去她家。路上，我们看到了很多公交车。它们被调转过来封锁了道路。而且，很多巨大的卡车，比如装甲车，就停在高速公路旁，封锁了道路。
All the government offices are shut down. The entire city is shut down. To get his passport, my dad now needs a letter from his workplace saying he didn't participate in the demonstrations. But there's a problem. He had to quit his job to apply for the passport. And they're saying that since he doesn't work there anymore, they can't provide him with that letter.
所有政府办公室都关闭了。整个城市都瘫痪了。为了拿到护照，我爸爸现在需要他工作单位的一封信，证明他没有参加示威活动。但有个问题。他必须辞职才能申请护照。而他们说因为他不再在那里工作，他们无法提供那封信。
My dad is freaking out. He staked his entire life on studying abroad. This was his plan, his future, his chance to leave his boring job in a Jeep factory, living in his tiny room in Beijing with no running water or heating or cooling. Now, his future is crumbling before his eyes. In this most desperate hour, my dad does something he's never done before.
我爸爸吓坏了。他把一生的筹码都压在了出国留学上。这是他的计划，他的未来，他离开北京吉普车工厂那份枯燥工作、住在那间没有自来水、供暖或制冷的小房间里的机会。现在，他的未来正在他眼前崩塌。在这个最绝望的时刻，我爸爸做了他以前从未做过的事情。
So I pray to God, OK, or Shang Di. I ask Shang Di to help me. So that's how I think I prayed for the first time.
所以我向神，上帝，或者“上帝”祈祷。我请求上帝帮助我。这就是我认为我第一次祈祷的方式。
Were you specifically praying to the God of Christianity at the time?
你当时是专门向基督教的上帝祈祷吗？
We don't have the habit of praying growing up. We don't have the habit of praying or talking to a god or something. So it just came natural, you know. I just lying on bed and say, oh, God, help me.
我们从小没有祈祷的习惯。我们没有祈祷或与神之类东西交谈的习惯。所以这只是自然而然发生的，你知道。我只是躺在床上说，哦，上帝，帮助我。
I never knew this story. I thought my dad's first encounter with God was in America. But two months earlier in Beijing, my dad naturally and spontaneously cried out to a God he didn't yet know or believe in. And then when his workplace finally gave him the letter that allowed him to leave China, it had to be God answering his prayer. So my dad was already primed to believe. And when he came to America, he would have encountered a Christian eventually, inevitably.
我从不知道这个故事。我一直以为我爸爸第一次接触上帝是在美国。但在两个月前的北京，我爸爸自然而然地自发地向一个他当时还不知道、也不相信的神哭诉。然后当他的工作单位最终给了他那封允许他离开中国的信时，那一定就是上帝回应了他的祈祷。所以我爸爸当时已经做好了相信的准备。当他来到美国时，他终究会不可避免地遇到基督徒。
So, I think in my case, I will meet someone else, and I will come to the faith, yeah.
所以，我想在我的情况下，我会遇到别人，我会皈依信仰，是的。
You would have eventually been exposed to Christianity, and you would have always, after having considered it, accepted it. Is that right?
你会最终接触到基督教，并且在考虑之后，你总是会接受它。对吗？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Why?
为什么？
Well, I think it's a fundamental truth. God is revealed to us in the Bible. And then everyone has to make a decision either to accept it or to reject it.
嗯，我认为这是一个根本的真理。上帝在圣经中向我们启示了祂自己。每个人都必须做出决定，要么接受它，要么拒绝它。
And you choose to accept it?
而你选择接受它？
Yes.
是的。
When my dad stood at the Oklahoma City airport waiting for someone to pick him up, I always thought that he stood at a crossroads, that if Dave hadn't appeared, my dad wouldn't have become Christian.
当我爸爸站在俄克拉荷马城机场等候接机时，我一直以为他站在十字路口，如果戴夫没有出现，我爸爸就不会成为基督徒。
But I understand now that he was ready to be a Christian. Norman's a small town. He probably would have run into Dave and his Chinese Ministry eventually. And even if my dad didn't go to Oklahoma, there are kind Christians with warm smiles in every city in America. So the airport didn't matter. There was never a crossroads. It was a straight line.
但我现在明白了，他已经准备好成为一名基督徒了。诺曼是个小镇。他很可能最终会遇到戴夫和他的华人事工。即使我爸爸没有去俄克拉荷马州，美国每个城市里都有带着温暖微笑的善良基督徒。所以机场并不重要。从来就没有什么十字路口。那是一条直线。
["DO YOU REALIZE??" BY SHARON VAN ETTEN]
【莎伦·范·埃滕演唱《你意识到吗？？》】
That story by Boen Wang. He's an audio producer living in Pittsburgh with his fiancée, Grace Gilbert, who came up with the title for today's episode. Boen's website, boen.cool. That's B-O-E-N dot cool.
这是博恩·王的故事。他是一位音频制作人，与未婚妻格蕾丝·吉尔伯特住在匹兹堡，是她想出了今天节目的标题。博恩的网站，boen.cool。就是B-O-E-N点cool。
Well, our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Barry.
嗯，我们的节目今天由莉莉·沙利文制作。参与今天节目的员工包括菲亚·本宁、迈克尔·科米特、亨利·拉尔森、塞思·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、萨菲亚·里德尔、瑞恩·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·巴里。
Special thanks today to Rebecca Curtis at the University of Oklahoma, Axin Hua, Jenny Lin, Manhong Liu, and Jesse Naus and Greta Zewe at Red Caiman Studios. This is our very last show with our production fellow Safiyah Riddle, who's done a great job here. She is off to do reporting for the Associated Press at her next job in Montgomery, Alabama. We hope she finds a story down there she can come back and do here on the radio.
今天特别感谢俄克拉荷马大学的丽贝卡·柯蒂斯、阿欣·华、珍妮·林、曼红·刘，以及红凯门工作室的杰西·瑙斯和格雷塔·泽韦。这是我们的制作成员萨菲亚·里德尔的最后一场节目，她在这里做得非常棒。她将前往阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利的下一份工作，为美联社进行报道。我们希望她在那里能找到一个故事，能回来并在我们的电台上播出。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. If you're looking for something to listen to on a long drive during the summer holiday, you can stream from our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。如果你正在寻找长途驾驶假期时可以听的东西，你可以免费流媒体收听我们800多集的档案。Thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he is the worst babysitter I have ever seen. Baby won't go to bed, starts crying. Torey's technique? He leans into the crib, looks into the baby's eyes, and says--
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他是我见过最差劲的保姆。宝宝不肯睡觉，开始大哭。托瑞的技术？他探进婴儿床，看着宝宝的眼睛说——
Why are you being so immature about this?
你为什么在这件事上表现得这么幼稚？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
["DO YOU REALIZE??" BY SHARON VAN ETTEN]
【莎伦·范·埃滕演唱《你意识到吗？？》】